vous savez à quel point c'est vrai on le
dit récemment que j'ai une belle
relation avec guillaume content
maintenant qu'on parle des fruits et
légumes
est révolue et j'avais jamais fait le
lien parce que moi je vois pas ces
choses là que tu m'envoies très souvent
désolé mais
[Applaudissements]
oui est-ce que je suivais gagnent ouais
c'est ça arrive et gagnent donc on
échange souvent autour des fruits et
légumes tu te fous de la gu retour dans
la galère en défaveur de la gueule du
monde entend longtemps jeu des questions
pour delphine travail j'ai été un peu
outré par les propos de raymond soeur
qui l'a draguée comme un crevard sur sur
affine est ce que tu préfères mois ou
l'abominable homme de rungis raymond
regardez quelqu'un j'ai l'impression à
gauche
non je suis extrêmement ça va oui
vraiment ça se voit d'ailleurs
des liens non mais non mais non non non
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]